and the compiler is hugging me and basically holding my hand as I learn the language. I feel like the Rust compiler hugs you while you're learning, and the C++ compiler actively punches you in the face. I hope you're still recording because that was... Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 101, recorded on October 27th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we live code some rust. We might do a little live coding. We said we'd never do this again, but I might need to join from my other laptop. But first things first.
编译器在拥抱我，在我学习这门语言时基本上是在手把手地教我。我觉得 Rust 编译器在你学习的时候会给你一个拥抱，而 C++ 编译器则会直接往你脸上狠狠地打一拳。希望你还在录音，因为刚才那段…… 欢迎来到 ADSP，播客第 101 期，录制于 2022 年 10 月 27 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们进行一些 Rust 的实时编码。我们可能会写一点实时编码。我们说过再也不做这种事了，但我可能需要从我的另一台笔记本电脑加入。但首先要说的是。
Actually, let me first join. This is going to be exciting, folks. We're going to start off with a Twitter poll. We haven't done a Twitter poll, I feel like, in months. Somehow it's not going to end well for me. No, no. It actually has nothing to do with us personally. But first things first
其实，让我先加入进来。各位，这将会非常激动人心。我们要从一个 Twitter 投票开始。我觉得我们已经有好几个月没做过 Twitter 投票了。不知怎么的，这对我来说不会有什么好结果。不，不。其实这跟我们个人完全没有关系。但首先要说的是
let me go to i gotta go to oh while i'm doing this let me explain to you i'll just this is completely random chocolate our listeners don't care about this but there's a website called city strides and it's basically keeps track of every road you've run on if you sync it with your Strava or Garmin. And I've recently become... And then it ranks you out of all the people on the website of how many roads you've run globally. And I have recently become addicted to this. Anyways, it's pretty neat. So for those of you that are running or walking and want to see all the streets you've ever walked on, go check out citystrides.com. All right.
让我去……我得去……哦，在我做这个的同时，我向你们解释一下，我只是……这完全是随机的巧克力，我们的听众并不关心这个，但有一个叫做 city strides 的网站，如果你把它和你的 Strava 或 Garmin 同步，它基本上会记录你跑过的每一条路。我最近迷上了……然后它会在网站上的所有人中，按你全球跑过的道路数量对你进行排名。我最近对这个上瘾了。总之，这挺酷的。所以对于你们这些跑步或走路，想看看自己走过所有街道的人，去看看 citystrides.com 吧。好了。
Let me share my screen. First, we're going to set a Twitter poll. And I guess actually we need to do this on Firefox because that's where desktop one share. Thanks for hanging in there, dear listener. All right. Let's open up Firefox now. And we are going to construct a tweet. And the tweet is...
让我分享一下我的屏幕。首先，我们要设置一个 Twitter 投票。我想实际上我们需要在 Firefox 上进行，因为那是桌面端共享的地方。感谢大家的坚持，亲爱的听众。好了。现在让我们打开 Firefox。我们要发一条推文，这条推文是……
I'll type it live, actually, so Bryce will... We'll keep Bryce on the edge of his seat. Ooh, we got some notifications first. Should we read the notifications? We are such a distractible podcast. Yeah. I mean, chaos with sprinkles of information. Stick with the...
其实我现场打出来，这样布莱斯就会……我们会让布莱斯拭目以待。哦，我们先收到了一些通知。我们要读一下通知吗？我们真是一个容易分心的播客。对。我是说，点缀着各种信息的混乱。坚持……
All right, we'll stick with the tweet. Here we go. Oh, look, we literally just got a notification. People... Oh, no, it's five hours ago. Here's the tweet. You're like my dog with a ball. It's like, she could be doing...
好吧，我们还是发推文吧。我们开始吧。哦，看，我们刚刚收到了一条通知。人们……哦，不，那是五小时前。推文是这样的。你就像抱着球的狗。就像，她本可以……
She could be eating. She could be sleeping. It's like, she could be doing anything. It's like, ball, ball, ball. Yeah, it's like that dog from Up. Anyways, the Twitter poll. Here we go. Poll.
她本可以吃东西。她本可以睡觉。就像，她本可以做任何事。就像，球，球，球。对，就像《飞屋环游记》里的那只狗。总之，Twitter 投票。我们开始吧。投票。
Ask a question. How do we ask this? What? Actually, it's really, it's a poll. Maybe it's a poll from my, so option one is ADSP temporarily becomes a, there's only 25 characters. What are you trying to pull? So there's like four other podcasts I want to start. And one of them is a Rust podcast.
问一个问题。我们怎么问？什么？其实，真的，这是一个投票。也许这是一个来自我的……所以选项一是 ADSP 暂时变成一个，只有 25 个字符。你到底想投什么票？所以还有其他四四个我想开始的播客。其中一个是 Rust 播客。
But I could start a Rust podcast or ADSP could just briefly become a Rust. I want to learn Rust. Yeah. All right. So that's what the poll is about. But apparently each choice, each option is only allowed 25 characters. Why are we taking a poll? This is not a democracy.
但我可以开一个 Rust 播客，或者 ADSP 可以短暂地变成一个 Rust……我想学 Rust。对。好吧，这就是投票的内容。但显然每个选择、每个选项只允许 25 个字符。我们为什么要投票？这不是民主。
The listener gets what the listener wants. Or the listener doesn't get what the listener wants listen it's what whatever we want i can't believe there's only there's only 25 characters i'm getting i'm getting chocolate not crunchy chocolate so it won't mess with the uh becomes uh it is in a paper bag which is not great for the audio. Oh, I also have caramels. Those are probably a better idea. I need help.
听众想要什么，听众就能得到什么。或者听众得不到他们想要的东西……听听，这是由我们说了算。我真不敢相信只有 25 个字符。我拿到了……巧克力，不是脆巧克力的那种，所以它不会弄乱……它装在一个纸袋里，这对音频来说不太好。哦，我还有焦糖糖果。那些可能是个更好的主意。我需要帮助。
I'm two characters. I need two more characters for the S and the T. What's a shorter word for becomes? ADS. This is. ADSP. You're doing this wrong. You put the options in the body and then you have like...
我有两个字符。S 和 T 我还需要两个字符。有什么比 becomes 更短的词吗？ADS。这是。ADSP。你这不对。你把选项放在正文中，然后你……
Oh, yeah. That's a good point. What should... Don't you know how to tweet, bro? What do listeners prefer? A, ADSP becomes... We'll say temporarily. Temporarily, temp, I can't spell temp,
哦，对。好主意。应该……老兄，你难道不会发推文吗？听众更喜欢什么？A，ADSP 变成……我们说暂时。暂时，temp，我不会拼 temp，
temporarily becomes a at rustling podcast. Or B, at code report starts a new wrestling only podcast. And then we put A and B. And we'll put this for a week. Does that look good?
暂时变成一个 rustling 播客。或者 B，@code report 开始一个新的纯 wrestling 播客。然后我们放 A 和 B。这个投票我们设为一周。这样看起来好吗？
Not even paying attention. It's just so focused on his chocolate. It's not chocolate. It's caramel. It's very good. I don't. It's not chocolate. It's caramel. It's very good. I don't think there's a point in doing this because I think we should just do A. I mean, we can just do A. I still want to send the poll, though.
甚至都没在听。他太专注于他的巧克力了。这不是巧克力。这是焦糖。非常好。我……这不是巧克力。这是焦糖。非常好。我觉得做这个没什么意义，因为我觉得我们直接选 A 就行。我的意思是，我们可以直接选 A。不过我还是想把投票发出去。
Why do you want to send the poll? I mean, because I've already had— Because either— What are the possible outcomes here? Either you get back a supportive answer, and we're going to do it anyways, so it doesn't influence the decision. All right. Or you get back an answer that,
你为什么非要发投票不可？我的意思是，因为我已经——因为不管是——这里可能有什么结果？要么你得到了一个支持的回答，反正我们都要这么做，所以它不会影响决定。好吧。要么你得到了一个回答，
oh, this thing that we're going to do anyways is going to offend our listeners. I mean, I might still... If people want a whole new podcast, this thing that we're going to do anyways is going to offend our listeners. I mean, I might still... If people want a whole new podcast, we could do both options. That's what I'll put. I'll put C both. Let's go to the live coding section.
哦，我们无论如何都要做的这件事会冒犯我们的听众。我的意思是，我可能还是……如果人们想要一个全新的播客，我们两个选项都可以做。这就是我要放上去的。我选 C，两个都要。我们进入实时编码环节吧。
I'm sending the poll out. I'm sending the poll out. A, B, C, seven days. Anything you want to modify before I click tweet? As a chair with experienced polling groups of people, I think this is a poll that you don't need to take. But you don't want to change it at all. You just don't think it should be sent.
我要把投票发出去了。我要把投票发出去了。A、B、C，七天。在我点击发送推文之前，你有什么要修改的吗？作为一个主持过富有经验的人群投票小组的人，我认为这是一个根本不需要进行的投票。但你一点也不想改。你只是觉得不该发出去。
Yeah. All right. I'm clicking tweet. You ready? Sure. It's sent. All right. Now I'm going to take my hoodie off to become more comfortable for this live coding thing one sec all right let's talk about should we ask a question first let's ask a question um i don't know how do we form this question how many functions do you think you need to call to idiomatically and when i say idiomatically i mean idiomatically from the point
好吧。我要点发送推文了。准备好了吗？当然。发送了。好了，现在我要脱掉连帽衫，为了接下来的实时编码感觉更舒服一点，等一下。好吧，我们来谈谈……我们应该先问个问题吗？我们先问个问题，呃……我不知道，我们该怎么表述这个问题？你觉得你需要调用多少个函数才能符合习惯用法——当我说符合习惯用法时，我的意思是站在一个不懂 Rust、几天前才刚开始尝试学习 Rust 的人的角度——去访问 Rust 中 vector 的第一个元素？所以这相当于……
of view from a person that doesn't know rust and just started trying to pick up rust like a few days ago access the first element of a vector in rust so the what is the equivalent um of vec.front or like, you know, if v is your vector and you go dot front. One. Pardon? One. I know that this, like, this has to be a trick, but one?
vec.front 的等价物，或者你知道的，如果 v 是你的 vector，你输入点 front。一。什么？一。我知道这……这肯定是个陷阱，但是一？
It is not one. I mean, just the way you set that up, I mean, of course, I know it's wrong, but that makes me sad and troubled. Let's actually, we'll do this. Three? I know it's wrong that makes me sad and troubled let's actually we'll do three I think it is I think it is three so let's go to God I knew it I knew it couldn't be two either because yeah if it's just one or two it wouldn't be amusing enough so we're in goblet now and uh let v equals vec exclamation mark
不是一。我是说，就你设定的这种方式，我的意思是，我当然知道这是错的，但这让我感到悲伤和困扰。实际上，我们这样……三？我知道这是错的，这让我感到悲伤和困扰。实际上，我们选三。我觉得是……我觉得就是三，所以我们去……天哪，我早就知道，我早就知道也不可能是二，因为对，如果只是一或二，那就不够有趣了。所以我们现在在 Godbolt 里，呃……let v = vec 惊叹号
one two three exclamation mark mean i know nothing about rust so this podcast is going to quickly become connor teaches brice rust yeah let's let's uh well let's um, let's put a disclaimer up front. Connor does not know Rust. Everything that I say here... You know more than me. ...could be potentially false. But my understanding is that the exclamation point means it's a macro. So both...
一二三惊叹号。意思是对于 Rust 我一无所知，所以这个播客很快就会变成“康纳教布莱斯学 Rust”。对，让我们……呃，好吧，让我们……先做个免责声明。康纳不懂 Rust。我在这里说的所有话……你知道的比我还多。……都有可能是错的。但我的理解是，感叹号意味着它是一个宏。所以两边……
Why is VEC a macro? That's just the syntax they use to indicate to the reader of the code and probably the compiler as well, that you are in macro land right now. So VEC. No, no, no.
为什么 VEC 是个宏？这只是他们使用的语法，用来向代码的阅读者、可能还有编译器表明：你现在处于宏的领域。所以 VEC……不，不，不。
But like what I, I understand that. Why is, why does VEC have to be a macro? Oh, because they don't have like a shortcut initialize initializer or list syntax for creating a list. So this is like the shortest way you can construct a list of numbers.
但就像我，我理解这一点。为什么 VEC 必须是一个宏？哦，因为他们没有像快捷初始化器或者用于创建列表的列表语法。所以这是你能构建数字列表的最短方式。
It makes sense. It makes sense. I think technically there is a literal array equivalent to the std array. But this is like, you know, for dealing with a vector equivalent to the std vector in C++, this is what you would use. So you can see here at the bottom we got 1, 2, 3. So my understanding is that if we want to get the first element, we have to go v either into or into iter. And then we have to go next.
这说得通。这说得通。我想严格来说，有一个与 std 数组等价的字面量数组。但这就好像，你知道的，对于处理相当于 C++ 中 std vector 的 vector，这就是你会使用的。所以你可以在底部看到我们得到了 1、2、3。所以我的理解是，如果我们想获取第一个元素，我们必须让 v 调用 into 或者 into iter。然后我们必须调用 next。
And then we have to go unwrap. then if we put i have a dumb question is there no like you can't just do like v open square brackets zero closed square brackets no like you wouldn't see plus plus so there's there's no like random access operator operation on a vector. The problem, I'm sure that you can define one of those, but the problem is that safety is everything in Rust. Yeah, I had a feeling that this was the reason why. And so like next, I believe returns, basically it's the equivalent of your like plus plus
然后我们必须调用 unwrap。然后如果我们放……我有一个愚蠢的问题，难道没有那种……你不能直接用 v 方括号 0 方括号吗？没有，就像在 C++ 里那样？所以 vector 上没有随机访问操作符或操作。问题是，我确信你可以定义一个这样的操作，但问题在于安全性在 Rust 中是一切。是的，我有种感觉，这就是原因。所以就像 next，我坚信它返回的基本上相当于 C++ 中的++
operator in C++, but it returns an option of the next element because you might have an empty list. So that's similar to like, if you're familiar with functional languages where they have head and tail, where head is equivalent to the first element, they also have like safe head, which returns you a maybe of the underlying type of your vector or list. And so because next is returning an option, you need to unwrap it.
操作符，但它返回的是下一个元素的 option（可选类型），因为你可能有一个空列表。这类似于，如果你熟悉函数式编程语言，它们有 head 和 tail（头和尾），其中 head 相当于第一个元素，它们还带有诸如 safe head 的功能，返回你的 vector 或底层类型的 maybe。所以因为 next 返回的是一个 option，你需要将它 unwrap。
And I'm sure there's a better way to do it than unwrap. But anyway, so the point is, is that in order to get the first element of a vector, you have to go v or whatever the name of your vector is, dot into iter,
而且我确信有比 unwrap 更好的方法。不过总之，重点是，为了获取 vector 的第一个元素，你必须输入 v 或者你的 vector 名字，点 into iter，
paren paren, dot next, paren paren, dot unwrap, paren paren. Is it possible that we're, that we're holding this wrong? whatever the name of your vector is,.intoiter.next.unwrap.semicolon. Is it possible that we're holding this wrong? Holding this? Yes, is it possible that we're holding this wrong and that in the Rust philosophy
括号括号，点 next，括号括号，点 unwrap，括号括号。有没有可能我们……我们这样用是不对的？不管你的 vector 叫什么名字，点 intoiter 点 next 点 unwrap 分号。有没有可能我们这样用是不对的？这样用？是的，有没有可能我们这样用是不对的，并且在 Rust 的哲学中
that doing this of getting the first element of a vector like this is not the idiomatic thing. I mean, let's go to Stack Overflow. How to get the first element from vector in Rust, which is just what I did a few days ago. I don't know what this is. Return first item of a vector. This is defining your own function. Yeah, but what I'm getting at is like, is there like
像这样获取 vector 的第一个元素并不是符合习惯用法的做法？我是说，我们去 Stack Overflow 看看。如何在 Rust 中从 vector 获取第一个元素，这正是我几天前做的。我不知道这是什么。返回 vector 的第一个项。这是定义你自己的函数。是的，但我的意思是……
is the reason that this is unwieldy because this is not the way that you should write Rust code? Maybe. I mean, but like literally the second top answer on this is using
这里面显得很笨拙的原因，是因为这不是你写 Rust 代码的正确方式吗？也许吧。我是说，但这里得票第二高的答案实际上就是在使用
into iter and then.enth. And I believe.enth is... What does into iter do? It turns it into an iterator. It basically turns it into something that implements the iter traits, which is sort of equivalent to ranges. So you can call a bunch of algorithms on it. You know, sort, reverse, et cetera, et cetera.
into iter 然后点 nth。我相信点 nth 是……into iter 是做什么的？它把它变成了一个迭代器。它基本上把它变成了一些实现 iter 特征（trait）的东西，这有点类似于 ranges（范围）。所以你可以对它调用一堆算法。（排序、反转等等等等。）
Anyways, this is just my first entry into Rust because I feel like... So, okay, I have some more questions. Like, couldn't you have an element access operator like you do in C++, but one that just returns you a maybe? Yes, I believe. Okay, so why... There must, like...
总之，这只是我进入 Rust 的初次尝试，因为我觉得……好吧，我还有更多问题。比如，你难道不能像在 C++ 中那样拥有一个元素访问操作符，但它返回一个 maybe 吗？是的，我相信可以。好吧，那为什么……
I'm sure we're not the first people to come across this. There must be a principled reason why Russ doesn't do this. Well, actually, first. Can we get, isn't Mara like the Russ Standard Library person? Mm-hmm. Can we get her on the podcast? I don't know. I know Jane is super involved, and we know her.
肯定……我确信我们不是第一个遇到这种情况的人。Rust 不这么做一定有其原则上的原因。好吧，其实首先。我们能把……Mara 不是 Rust 标准库的那个人吗？嗯哼。我们能请她上播客吗？我不知道。我知道 Jane 深度参与了，我们认识她。
We can get Jane on. Also, too, we should definitely have on JT, Jason's cousin, because he works both on Rust and on Yacht, or Yacht, or Jacked, or whatever the language that's in Serenity OS. So we can ask about two languages at once. Does Rust have bracket? Yeah, Mara is the Rust slang library
我们可以请 Jane 来。还有，我们绝对应该请 JT 来，也就是 Jason 的表弟，因为他既从事 Rust 的工作，也从事 Yacht、或者 Yacht、或 Jacked、或者是 Serenity OS 里的那个语言的工作。所以我们可以同时问关于两种语言的问题。Rust 有方括号吗？对，Mara 是 Rust 语言标准库
team lead. So we should have her on. Does Rust have bracket? So it actually looks like it might not. It might not actually have that. Okay, it doesn't have to be brackets. It could be a function called like, you know, at which is a name of a much yes much less useful function in on vector and c plus plus
团队负责人。所以我们应该邀请她。Rust 有方括号吗？所以实际上看起来它可能没有。它实际上可能没有那个。好吧，不一定非得是方括号。它可以是一个名为……你知道的，比如 at 的函数，这是一个在 C++ vector 中
an app could return you a rust maybe it could take like an index and return you a rest maybe like why doesn't why doesn't rust have this let's go to the ap. I suspect it's... I mean, you also have to understand is that... Hang on, hang on. I see a vec 0 there. Where? Like... 0?
极其不常用的函数的名称。at 可以返回一个 Rust 的 maybe。它可以接受一个索引并返回一个 Rust 的 maybe……为什么……为什么 Rust 没有这个？让我们去看看 API。我猜它……我的意思是，你也必须明白……等等，等等。我看到那里有一个 vec 0。在哪？就像……0？
I see a vec, open brackets, 0, close brackets. Okay, let's go try that. We're not going to have content for an episode. Oh, what the F? What the actual F? All right, folks. Did you not try this? Well, we're not airing this.
我看到一个 vec，开括号，0，闭括号。好吧，我们去试试那个。我们不会有足够的节目内容了。哦，什么鬼？这到底是什么鬼？好吧，各位。你没试过这个吗？好吧，我们不会播出的。
We're going to need something else. No, we're definitely, what do you mean? We're definitely, why would we not try this uh well we're not we're not we're not airing this we're gonna need something else no we're definitely mean we're definitely why would we why would we not air this why would we not air this um uh so let's let me just stash let me stash my current changes um and you really want the world to know that you uh man why do i shouldn't have to man that this is bad shame on you bryce shame on uh you like basically trying to make a beginner developer that's learning about a technology not like feel bad about themselves this is why people don't want to get up on stage at conferences and give talks and stuff because like you're trying to make Oh you want you want people to know that you didn't know of course. I didn't know I'm learning the language and Stack overflow didn't tell me that this is possible, but let's let's go and check if this actually I
我们需要点别的。不，我们绝对……你什么意思？我们绝对……为什么我们不试一试这个……呃，我们不播这个，我们需要点别的。不，我们绝对……我是说，我们绝对……为什么我们不播这个？为什么我们不播这个？呃……呃，所以，让我暂存一下，让我把当前的更改暂存起来……你真的想让全世界都知道你……老兄，为什么我不应该……老兄，这太糟了。真丢脸，布莱斯，真丢脸……你就像是在试图让一个正在学习某项技术的初学者感到自我感觉不好。这就是为什么人们不想上会议舞台去做演讲之类的事情，因为就像你在试图让……哦，你想让人们知道你不知道，当然。我不知道，我正在学习这门语言，Stack Overflow 也没有告诉我这是可能的，但让我们去检查一下这究竟是不是……
Appreciate your efforts to save this episode Man, it's not nice buddy. Not nice. So let's go check if this actually works. Yeah, don't save. Go back here. All right, so now we're in live code, and I'm just changing where I had an into iter next unwrap, changing this to angle bracket zero. And now let us try and build and see what happens move occurs because the value of type t which does not implement the copy trait
感谢你为挽救这一期节目所做出的努力。老兄，这可不太友好，兄弟，一点也不友好。所以我们去检查一下这到底能不能行。对，不保存。回到这里。好了，现在我们在实时代码中，我正在把我之前写 into iter next unwrap 的地方，改成尖括号 0。现在让我们尝试构建一下，看看会发生什么。移动发生了，因为类型 t 的值没有实现 copy 特征
helps uh consider borrowing here all right we will do that also how wonderful i mean bryce has left his computer so we're not really live coding anymore um no no i'm i'm watching i'm just like like, I'm on the ground. I'm looking up. Look, the dog needs attention. I can do two things at once. And this is what is amazing about Rust. This is compiler just... Yeah, I mean, that's a pretty good diagnostic. I mean, especially...
有帮助……考虑在此处借用。好吧，我们照做。另外，多么奇妙啊——我是说布莱斯已经离开他的电脑了，所以我们其实已经不再实时编码了……不，不，我看着呢。我只是……就像，我在地上。我抬头看。看，狗狗需要关注。我可以同时做两件事。这就是 Rust 令人惊叹的地方。这个编译器只是……是的，我的意思是，这是一个相当不错的诊断信息。我是说，尤其是……
It just told me basically exactly what to do. And you are incredibly correct look at this so we're now we're gonna do a little nice little beautiful refactor here i want to i want to i want to i want to take a step back and um i want to understand what did did you not try this i didn't know that this was possible but but why didn't you try it? Because that's what you're used to doing, right? I feel like it didn't work.
它基本上准确地告诉我该做什么。而且你非常正确。看看这个，所以现在我们要在这里做一个漂亮的、小小的重构。我想……我想……我想……我想退一步，并且……我想了解，难道你没试过这个吗？我不知道这是可能的，但是……但是你为什么不试一下呢？因为那是你习惯的做法，对吧？我觉得它行不通。
Okay, because I feel like you must have tried it. It works here as well. And... It is funny how often this happens where you think you've discovered some problem or something and, um, and then you go to show somebody else. And then as you're showing it to somebody else, it's like the, the, it becomes immediately clear that, oh no, it wasn't a problem.
好吧，因为我觉得你肯定试过。这里它也行得通。而且……这就很有趣，这种情况经常发生：你以为你发现了什么问题或者别的什么，然后……然后你去展示给别人看。接着，当你在向别人展示的时候，它就像是……情况立刻变得清晰起来，哦，不，根本不是什么问题。
You just, there was just confusion or misunderstanding or something. And I think merely the act of explaining something to other people. Well, I mean, this is the power of pair programming. Yeah. So look at this. Now we've got a diff replacing every single into, it, or next unwrapped with just angle bracket zero.
你只是……只是存在困惑或误解之类的。而且仅仅是向其他人解释这一行为……好吧，我是说，这就是结对编程的力量。是的。所以看看这个。现在我们有了一个 diff，将每一个 into、iter、next unwrap 都替换成了单纯的尖括号 0。
Although note, and that's the thing. So in Rust, my understanding is- I think i know i think i now know what happened what you probably were looking for like a dot front or something um and i think that's because of like this is again a good example of the difference in type of programmer that we are. My gut reaction was to reach for angle bracket zero if I want the first element of a thing. Because to me, from more of the systems programming background, it's just the first element in a contiguous array of memory. Or really it's more the pointer syntax of which I am used to working with
虽然注意，这就是关键所在。所以在 Rust 中，我的理解是……我想我知道……我想我现在知道发生了什么了。你当时可能在寻找类似 dot front 的东西，我想那是因为……这也是我们作为不同类型程序员的差异的一个很好的例子。我的直觉反应是去用尖括号 0，如果我想要某个东西的第一个元素。因为对我来说，从更多的系统编程背景来看，它只是连续内存块中的第一个元素。或者实际上，它更像是我习惯使用的指针语法，
as somebody who writes a lot of low-level code. Whereas you, I think the first thing that you would reach for would be something like.front. And you would probably think that something like open bracket uh zero close bracket is in some way inelegant and so maybe you didn't try that maybe you tried that front and you never tried this that is probably some good what do you call it reverse historianing in that probably that is what i did is i looked for front didn't find front frowned next but next didn't work.
作为一个编写大量底层代码的人。而你，我想你首先会去寻找的东西类似于 dot front。你可能会觉得像方括号 0 这样的东西在某种程度上不够优雅，所以也许你没有尝试过那个。也许你尝试了 dot front，但从来没有试过这个。这大概是个很好的……你把它叫什么来着？逆向历史叙事，我大概就是这么做的：我找了 front，没找到 front，皱了眉头，然后试了 next，但 next 行不通。
And in order to use next, you had to call into iter, but that gave you an optional. And so in order to get the value out of the optional, you had to go unwrap. And then I said, wow, this is pretty awful. I never thought to check just bracket, bracket, zero. Yeah.
为了使用 next，你必须调用 into iter，但这给了你一个可选类型（optional）。为了从可选类型中获取值，你必须调用 unwrap。然后我说：“哇，这太糟糕了。”我从来没想过去检查仅仅是方括号、方括号、0。对。
Bracket, zero, bracket. But how do you get back? Can you do bracket, like, minus one, close bracket? Does that work with West vectors? Let's find out. Because, like, what I'm getting at is that
方括号、0、方括号。但是你该怎么退回去呢？你能用方括号，比如 -1，闭方括号吗？这在 Rust 的 vector 中行得通吗？我们来找找看。因为，我的意思是，
if you have the element access operator that takes an index, it's trivial to get front because it's always zero. But what about back? Well, first, let's commit this. Also, what is the Rust vector element access return? What happens if it's out of bounds?
如果你拥有一个接受索引的元素访问操作符，获取 front 就变得微不足道，因为索引总是 0。但 back 呢？好吧，首先，我们提交这个。还有，Rust 的 vector 元素访问返回什么？如果越界了会发生什么？
I don't think that's possible. Like the borrow checker. So yeah, let's first commit this. Use vec, because I'll even put your name, because B. Lelback, B. Lelback is a good friend. We push that. Boom, all right, now back to Godbolt. And we haven't even gotten to the main,
我觉得那是不可能的。就像借用检查器。所以是的，我们先提交这个。使用 vec，因为我甚至会写上你的名字，因为 B. Lelback。B. Lelback 是个好朋友。我们推送它。轰，好了，现在回到 Godbolt。我们甚至还没进主函数，
so this is great, because we're closing in on a second episode here. And then we're going to be able to dedicate a whole, maybe not a whole, but a third episode to the scan algorithm, which is really what I wanted to get to. So Bryce asks, what happens if you go out of bounds? Let's see. We go to V, bracket, 3. And I'm guessing this is not going to compile.
所以这太棒了，因为我们正在接近第二期节目，然后我们将能够投入整整一期——也许不是整整一期，但可以把第三期奉献给 scan 算法，这正是我一直想讲的。所以布莱斯问，如果你越界了会发生什么？我们来看看。我们访问 V，方括号，3。我猜这不会编译通过。
ThreadMain panicked at index out of bounds. Ah, it compiled and ran and led to a runtime error. But I thought Rust was supposed to protect us from these things. Okay, now try negative one. I want to see what happens, whether that gives you back. Negative integers cannot be used. This did not compile. Okay, so then why isn't there a back?
线程 Main 在索引越界处发生 panic（恐慌）。啊，它编译并运行了，但导致了运行时错误。但我以为 Rust 应该保护我们免受这些事情的影响呢。好吧，现在试试负一。我想看看会发生什么，看看它是否会给你返回……负整数不能使用。这没有编译通过。好吧，那为什么没有 back 呢？
Well, we didn't actually finish looking at the API. So there's a.len which we can use. This is a lot of things. Why does it need so many things? V.len minus one. So V bracket V dot len paren paren minus one bracket, which is what you would do in many languages. Pretty ugly.
嗯，我们其实并没有看完 API。所以有一个 dot len，我们可以用它。这有很多东西。为什么它需要这么多东西？V.len 减 1。也就是 V 方括号 V 点 len 括号括号减 1 方括号，这正是你在许多语言中所做的。挺丑陋的。
I feel like they should make negative one. Yeah, it's potential. It's a possibility in the future. All right, that'll wrap up. All right, go ahead. You got a question before we move? Okay, answer the answer is that if you go out of bounds it panics um and there's no back okay well also if you are a rust informed individual i will leave a link in the show notes of this episode to the commit that I pushed to this
我觉得他们应该把负一加进去。是的，这是有可能的。未来存在这种可能性。好吧，那就到此为止。好吧，你先请。在我们继续之前，你有问题吗？好吧，答案是如果你越界了它会 panic，而且没有 back。好的，另外，如果你是一个精通 Rust 的人，我会在本期节目的 Show Notes（节目文稿）中留下链接，指向我推送到这个小玩具仓库的提交。如果你想去看这个更改以及我之前的代码——它是不是更符合习惯用法，这也是为什么它会出现在 Stack Overflow 上。而用方括号 0 方括号来获取第一个元素被认为是不好的，因为它在运行时会 panic。无论如何，这次很有教育意义。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
little toy repository. If you want to go look at this change and potentially my code that I had before, is it more idiomatic, which is why it was on stack overflow. And the bracket zero bracket to get the first one is considered bad because it panics at runtime. But anyways, this has been educational. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
小玩具代码仓库。如果你想去看这个改动以及我之前的代码，它是不是更符合惯用写法，这就是它为什么会出现在 Stack Overflow 上的原因。用方括号零方括号来获取第一个元素被认为是不好的，因为它会在运行时发生 panic。但不管怎样，这次很有教育意义。谢谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。